hey guys it's good to see you again I'm
back today with the fun and simple
little experiments that you can try at
home the only materials are going to
need for this project are an apple a
knife a ziplock bag and some paper towel
now for this project today I thought
it'd be fun to see if we could actually
sprout an apple seed now when you were a
kid there's a good chance your parents
told you not to eat apple seeds or
swallow watermelon seed because it would
sprout a tree in your stomach but that's
not necessarily true because there's
quite a process to getting a seed to
sprout and that is the purpose of this
experiment today now to get started we
need to extract the seeds from our Apple
and so you could just eat it and pull
the seeds out as you do or you could
grab a knife and cut very carefully at a
45 degree angle to the center
okay so once you've got your seeds
separated from the apples go ahead and
grab one sheet of paper towel and
something like this little water mixture
all we're going to do is take our paper
towel we're going to fold it in half
lengthwise and set it down the counter
we're going to use our little mixture to
give it five to six sprays on one side
then flip it over and give it five to
six shots on the other side the goal is
we want to get this things damp but we
don't want it to be wet all right with
our paper towel moistened we can go
ahead and take a few of our apple seeds
and place them down into a line
somewhere in the top half area the only
thing left to do after that is to fold
the paper towel in half over top of the
seeds place it into the ziplock bag and
seal it tight so there we have a guys
just like that we now have five of our
apple seeds tucked away inside with
moist paper towel and locked into the
block bag by the way it's not a bad idea
to mark the date under the bag so you
know when the three weeks is up the only
thing left to do now is to tuck this
away deep into the back of our fridge
and completely forget about it for the
next three weeks now it's just magic of
editing we fast forward into the future
three weeks with a simple clap of our
hand boom here we are three weeks later
let's go check our result
all right I'm actually really curious to
see what we got here this bag has done
nothing but sit in that fridge for three
weeks in the dark completely in neglect
didn't the first thing I notice is the
paper towel is actually still quite
moist still quite down which would make
sense because it was in a sealed ziplock
bag
all right let's peel back the top layer
until we've got oh my goodness look at
that our seeds have actually sprouted
some more than others these two over
here seem to have taken off quite
vigorously and viciously and these two
over here you can see little sprouts and
this one's got a little blood coming out
there as well all five of our seeds was
sprouted which i think is pretty cool
and now if we wanted to we could move
these things to a seed starter to help
them establish some roots and begin
budding into a tree and if we wanted to
we could actually grow them into apple
trees which is kind of mind-blowing but
I have to crush your expectation even if
you put years and years of effort into
growing your own apple tree the chances
of your apples tasting like the one you
grew this from are very very slim the
reason is because in our industry today
most of the apples are grafted onto
existing root structures so even though
you use the seeds from an apple you like
the apples you grow from it will taste
completely different so there you have
it guys now you know how to take the
seeds right out of the apples you're
eating stick them in the fridge for a
few weeks and grow an apple tree right
in your own backyard thanks for joining
me for this experiment I'll be looking
for the next one talk to you then
so though but now you know what the
paper towels for hey guys thanks for
watching and remember I'm giving away
prizes now on every new video all you
have to do to qualify is subscribed to
my channel ring the bell and select to
be notified when my next videos get
released the secret link to my giveaways
will be pinned in the comments for the
first 12 hours if you like what I'm
doing show your support right now by
giving this video a big thumbs up and
share with a friend I love you back I'll
see you next time